holiday shopping is well underway we
want to make sure
you're in the know when it comes to the
season's hottest toys
joining me is a senior editor at ttpm
that's toys tots pets and more laurie
leahy
to give us a sneak peek now lori
las vegas loves its nascar and if you
have a younger fan of the sport it looks
like you've got the perfect gift
yes the team nascar crash circuit course
from far out toys is perfect for kids
who love racing ages five and up
it comes with some cars that only charge
up in 10 seconds or less
so it's really quick to get them out on
the 14 feet of track to race
and they do have breakaway parts so that
in case they crash
there's a little bit more uh racing
action going on there so this is going
to be great for young kids
or older kids who enjoy racing cars it's
about 49.99
yeah i actually am very interested in
that one let's talk about beyblade what
do you have
uh the rise hyper sphere that sounds
kind of cool
yeah so this is another way for kids to
have some battling action it's the burst
rise hyper sphere from hasbro
uh so there are brand new these battling
spinning tops for kids to collect
kids love kind of combining the pieces
from their different beyblades to kind
of create the ultimate beyblade and with
these if you spin them
in the new beyblade um hypersphere uh
bay stadiums
they will rise up the side so it looks
really really cool and just again adds
more to that action-packed play and
these are for ages eight and up
okay i love that i love the action but
then also we want to use
our minds too when it comes to playing
what toy do you have for that
so this one's great for kids and adults
it's roto brain from creative brain
works for ages eight and up
there are three levels to unlock and you
have to figure out
which three color combos are going to
unlock each level
um it's going to take you a while it's
definitely a challenging
brain teaser puzzle game if you like
those kinds of things
and the whole movement of it reminds me
of turning the dial on your high school
locker
if you if you remember that so it's just
it's that kind of moving and twisting it
and just
using your brain to figure out how to
unlock the puzzle so it's a lot of fun
that's like next level rubik's cube like
time okay let's talk about something
that my little one loves
the lol surprise what do they have in
store for us this season
okay so brand new is the remix
collection
and this is a music themed collection of
dolls you've got the big dolls like i
have here you can purchase them
individually the small dolls they're
even pets
but what ultimate ella well fans will
want is the super surprise
from mga for ages five and up it's kind
of a big ticket item it's a huge box it
comes with eight
dolls and musical instruments that play
music so if you
love lol you are definitely going to
want to unbox everything in this
boombox themed playset and the whole
thing can actually kind of become a
concert stage or like a back a backstage
dressing room
so there's a lot of play going on in
just this one
huge box so it's definitely worth it if
you love lol that is amazing i love it
okay from
from lowell surprise to vip pets what do
you have for me right so
yeah we're going to finish it off a lot
of unboxings here um so vip pets is from
imc toys
and this is just a new way to collect
really cute uh pets
it's kind of like a hair salon
experience where you're kind of like
shampooing giving them a bath to unbox
the
the pet that's inside and when you do
get that unboxed
there's this beautiful long hair so lots
of great creative hair styling with the
accessories
you can mix and match lots of different
pets to collect you're going to love
getting creative with these so these are
super cute for ages three and up
that's right i don't watch those 99 each
and i just i love the hairspray bottle
too it's so clever
that is so adorable yeah the packaging
is everything okay we only have a few
seconds left but what would a holiday
season be without
barbie i know so barbie from mattel
color reveal slumber party surprise
more than 50 things to unbox inside this
huge set so definitely if you're a
barbie fan
you love it you put the doll in the
water you reveal what the doll is it
kind of takes you through a slumber
party game to unbox all the accessories
and then you have a cool slumber party
themed playset and you can add all your
other barbies to it so it's a really fun
unboxing experience for barbie fans ages
three and up thank you so much lori
that's quite a haul you can see all of
these toys
at ttpm.com las vegas now we'll be
right back